les rachats d'alstom ça devait créer des
milliers d'emplois aujourd'hui c'est des
destructions massives d'emplois ont dit
qu'ils n'ont pas créer 1000 emplois mais
en réalité on le détruit des milliers en
france
combien de temps ça va durer quoi
combien de temps le gouvernement va
accepter que une entreprise américaine
prennent le pouvoir sur la filière
énergétique française détruisent nos
emplois à un parent détruisent notre
centre d'excellence mondial de l'énergie
c'est la seule ville au monde vous avez
les meilleurs turbines à gaz du mas du
marché les meilleurs ordinateurs et
l'émir tum vapeur on est en train de
détruire un comment dire une histoire
industrielle de 140 ans on est en train
de détruire l'avenir de l'industrie en
france